JULIE WISKIRCHEN: Hi everybody.
I'm Julie Wiskirchen from
the Authors at Google team
in Los Angeles.
And today, we're excited
to welcome Valerie Gordon.
Valerie is a self-taught baker.
And she opened
Valerie Confections
in Los Angeles'
Silver Lake District
in 2004 to immediate acclaim.
Today, the company has expanded
to include three locations, as
well as a tremendous
online retail business.
She's been featured in "Vogue,"
"House and Garden," "Newsweek,"
"In Style," "USA Today," "Bon
Appetit," "Food and Wine,"
"The Splendid Table,"
and The Cooking Channel.
And today, she's here
to talk about her brand
new dessert cookbook,
"Sweet," and she's
going to teach as one of the
fabulous recipes from the book.
So please join me in
welcoming Valerie Gordon.
[APPLAUSE]
VALERIE GORDON: I have a really
quick favor to ask everybody.
Can you hold up your
copy of "Sweet"?
I tweetered for the very first
time today, which is huge.
This is going to be my
second tweeter ever.
And you're all
going to be in it.
I'm really into this.
OK, wait.
Wait, OK.
I have to press the thing.
Someone had to text
me how to do this.
And then I go, I do
the little quill thing.
And then I'm supposed
to take a picture.
"Sweet" up!
OK, and then I go like that.
Oh my God.
So cute.
OK, wait, wait.
Hold it up.
Go "Sweet."
Thank you.
And everyone's going
to follow us, right.?
Although I don't
know the handle.
[LAUGHTER]
VALERIE GORDON: OK,
it's @valerieconfctns.
OK, and then I was
told I'm supposed
to do the geography thing so
people know I'm at Google.
And then I go, OK, and
then I say, go Google.
#gogoogle, right?
OK, #gogoogle.
Tweet.
I did it.
Thank you so much
for coming today.
This is a thrill, I have to say.
As I was telling Julie, when I
saw this visit on my itinerary,
I got nervous.
Because I'm literally
a fan of Google.
And I would not have
been able to write
this cookbook without Google.
And I can't tell
you how many times,
while I was writing the
manuscript at like 2:00
in the morning, I
was like, oh God.
How do I convert that?
Google helped me through it.
Synonym for delicious.
Synonym for moist.
Where you're just
like, oh my god,
I can't write that
word one more time.
And there's just a
limit to the number
of times you can
write "moist cake"
and have it not
become kind of weird.
So thank you.
Thank you to Google.
Your offices are amazing.
And this place is
totally inspirational.
Has anyone here made jam before?
Anyone?
Once, twice, three times?
OK, cool.
So, I have a very
straightforward way
of making jam.
And one my things about making
jam is that all you're doing,
and what you need
to focus on most,
is your main purpose with jam
is to remove water and implement
sugar.
That's all you're doing.
So this heating
process, all we're doing
is helping the water evaporate.
And we're breaking down
fruit and impregnating
what is left over with sugar.
That's it.
I am not an advocate of pectin.
I think that pectin creates an
unnatural, overly gelatinous
texture, and detracts
from the fruit.
We are incredibly lucky
here in Southern California
to be able to get just the
most gorgeous produce any day
of the week.
You know, I talk to people
in the Pacific Northwest,
on the east coast, and they're
like, you got what today?
You got blueberries today?
That's bizarre.
We have squash here.
That's all we have.
So here in sunny
Los Angeles, it's
like year round you can
make delicious jams.
I also think one of the reasons
why jamming, marmalades,
pickles, all this stuff
has become so popular
is because of where
produce is at today.
Because we see these
farmers markets
in every neighborhood
every day of the week.
And we get to take
advantage of it.
So, jam.
Today I'm making what I think
is pretty much the easiest
kind of jam that you can make.
Anyone can do this.
So all I did was I cut up
five pounds of strawberries,
fresh strawberries.
And my magic ratio
is five pounds
of fruit to four cups of sugar.
That is a great starting point.
And some of you who've
made jam before may say,
that's a really low
amount of sugar.
That's absolutely correct.
Because jam should taste
like fruit and not sugar.
And I use just enough for
you to safely preserve it.
You know, sugar's like salt.
Once you add it, you
can't take it out.
So it's good to start low
and then slowly increase
as you're cooking and tasting.
The way I generally
cook jams, the way
I advise to cook jams in
the book, is to macerate.
Macerate means to let the
fruit sit for a bit of time
with sugar.
What that does is that actually
reduces your cooking time,
which is a really nice thing.
The first few
times I made jam, I
had some very experienced
pastry chefs show me how.
And I was just sort of curious.
Like, what's your jam process?
What's your deal?
You know what I mean?
And I was shown some
rather torturous methods
for jam making, where you
stand over the pot for hours
and hours and hours.
And this thing's like
splashing in your face.
And I was like,
well, I don't really
have time to stir a pot
for two hours, personally.
And most people don't.
You know what I mean?
It's like that's where
people sort of step away
from making things
to buying things.
If you macerate fruit, that
will cut down your cooking time.
It actually cuts down
your active time.
And it tends to extract more
of the juices from the fruit.
So while that sugar is
sitting with the fruit,
with the prepared fruit, it
starts to break down the fruit.
The sugars start to
come out of the fruit.
So you get a really
great, full flavor.
From there-- and what
I generally advise
is to macerate for an hour.
You could also stick it in your
refrigerator for a day or two.
So this can break up the
activity a little bit.
Say you're making
strawberry vanilla bean jam.
Say you're making plum jam.
You're making peach jam.
Whatever it is, say you've
got a half hour in your day.
You can prepare the
fruit, mix it with sugar,
cover it, put it in your
refrigerator for half a day,
for a day.
The next day, you come back.
And then you cook it and
can it, or just cook it
and store it in
the refrigerator.
I think it makes it just sort of
a more reasonable and realistic
process for those
of us that work
and have children
and have lives.
Most people can't just
spend two days making jam
at their leisure.
But that would be cool, but
most people can't do that.
So right now, all I'm doing,
I have this on a high heat.
And it's always good to
start at a high heat.
We just want to break it down.
We just want to break down the
fruit and get rid of the water.
So we have to bring this
concoction up to boiling.
That's the first
thing that we do.
And you move it a little
bit, but again, you
don't have to stand
here and work yourself
into a massive sweat.
Like there's a significant
amount of water in here,
and it'll just start to
boil, almost like soup.
And we just keep an eye on
it, stirring it occasionally.
Right now, what I might do
is already take a taste.
You always want to
taste as you cook.
Put it in your mouth.
Or else you have no
idea what you're doing.
Don't wait until the end.
Because if you're
making jam, whatever
it is that you're making,
don't wait until the end.
Taste as you go,
taste as you go.
And tweak in a way that's
most appealing to your palate.
So that totally is enough sugar.
So I'm not going to
do anything to that.
I'm just going to totally leave
that alone and add our vanilla
beans.
So vanilla beans,
these are great.
These are gorgeous pods.
And if you get them,
you want to break down
the vanilla bean a little bit.
And by rolling it between
your fingers like this--
you do generally store vanilla
beans in the refrigerator.
Let them come to
room temperature
before you start
to play with them.
And then you want to roll
them a little bit like this
to loosen the beans
inside from the pod.
You can scrape the
beans off a lot easier
that way if you do that.
So the whole thing,
top to bottom,
I'm just rolling it
in my fingertips.
And then you take the
sharp paring knife.
And you just run it down
the center of the bean.
And then you fan it
open, just like this.
And then you want to
scrape out those beans.
It's really, really pretty,
and incredibly aromatic.
So we just scrape that out.
And this whole thing
is going into the pot.
The pod and the beans impart a
really wonderful, warm, sweet,
delicious vanilla bean
flavor to this jam.
And then we stir that in.
If you're a big
fan of vanilla bean
and you're making
this jam, or you
decide to add vanilla bean to
whatever, and you're macerating
and you really want to see
a lot of that vanilla bean,
you want to taste a lot of
that vanilla mean, put it
in a before you macerate.
And that will increase the
amount of vanilla bean flavor.
You can also put a vanilla
bean in a bottle of vodka.
And it does a really
good thing if you
go in that direction, FYI.
Any questions?
Any questions on jam making?
On marmalades?
On anything fruity?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are there any jams
with pectin that you do use?
VALERIE GORDON: I don't
use any artificial pectin.
My jams are a
little bit, what you
would call in the
jamming community, loose.
So that means they
move a little bit.
I think that's OK.
Fruit and sugar
move a little bit.
What you can do in order
to naturally firm up
a jam or something like that
is to create a pectin sack.
The way that you create a
pectin sack is by using lemons.
Lemons and apples are
two things that naturally
hold an enormous
amount of pectin.
And they will help
fruit and sugar gel.
So you can either take
a bit of cheesecloth
and a few lemon seeds,
and some apple seeds,
and put them in the cheesecloth,
tie it up real tight,
and put it into the jam pot
while you're making jam.
And that will give
you a stiffer jam.
An easier way to do this
is by using a tea ball.
You can fill a tea
ball with lemon seeds.
And that will help your
jam firm a little bit more.
Just drop it right in.
And the cheesecloth,
if you don't
tie it quite tight enough,
it could come open.
Then you have lemon seeds
throughout your jam.
And you don't want that.
So as you can see, I'm just
moving this ever so slightly
around the pot.
The one area you do want to
be careful of when you're
making jam, marmalade,
is the corner of the pot.
That's where fruit
can tend to stick.
So you want to get
into that corner.
I also tend to use a
heat-proof spatula.
Because you're covering a
greater surface area then
with a rounded, wooden
spoon, where you're just
getting that tip of
the spoon, Where here,
I'm getting about 2 and
1/2 inches of pot coverage.
And then I can just
keep it moving.
I also recommend moving
in one direction.
Because then you know that
you're stirring consistently.
AUDIENCE: Do you ever
use raw sugar instead?
VALERIE GORDON: You
could use raw sugar.
You absolutely could.
You could use brown sugar.
You could use some other
sugars that I've played with.
Honey gets tricky.
I find agave syrup to be a
really, really interesting,
natural sweetener.
It is sweeter than sugar.
So you have to play with your
levels a little bit with agave.
And it won't firm up
quite as much in a jam
as a normal sugar will.
Mexican sugars, like all
of those sort of-- they're
these pyramid-shaped sugars.
Someone else might know
something about that.
But they have this really great,
caramelized, amazing flavor,
that if your pallet goes
in that direction, do it.
There are a couple of
recipes in the book where
I blend brown sugar
and white sugar,
just because the flavors
that are being played with,
it brings out a
different kind of nuance.
Again, if you are somebody
who likes citrus flavor,
you can add lemon zest to this.
And you'll get that note coming
out, which is pretty fun.
Alcohol additions are really
nice things to do in jams.
So if you like brandy,
if you like cognac,
if you like any of
those kinds of flavors,
adding those to the end,
think of it as an extract.
Right?
Just like a really
subtle flavoring.
If you like spice, throw
in a cinnamon stick.
Throw in some clove to whatever
fruit you're playing with.
The idea that I'm getting
to here, of course,
is do whatever you want
to do with your jam.
It's your jam.
Have fun with it.
Play with it.
Everyone's got a slightly
different palette.
And just have fun with it.
It's such an easy thing to do.
So easy to do at home.
And then you have these
wonderful, fresh homemade
condiments that
you can play with.
Anyone else?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do you have to
start with fresh fruit,
or could you use frozen fruit?
VALERIE GORDON: You can
totally use frozen fruit.
Absolutely.
Defrost it and use it.
You absolutely can.
The water content will
be a little bit lower.
There are a couple
recipes in the book,
the fig recipes in particular.
Figs have a very, very
low water content.
So in order to cook
something, you need a conduit.
Right?
The conduit being water.
That is, the carrier of heat
that will help you break down
the fruit, or whatever
ingredient you're using.
So you might need to add
a little bit of water
if you're using frozen fruit.
You can also
rehydrate dried fruit.
So say you're doing the
white fig, Fuji apple vanilla
bean jam that's in the book.
And you've got your
gorgeous white figs.
You went out you got a case
of these gorgeous kadota white
figs and you are ready to go.
And they're like, oh my God.
I don't have Fuji apples.
But you've got some dried
apples in your cabinet.
Soak those dried
apples in hot water.
And you can hydrate them, and
then cook them in the jam.
Apricots, you can do that too.
A lot of dried fruits
can be rehydrated.
Anyone else?
See, oh.
This is where we
need the camera.
So this is bubbling up
really, really high right now.
It's sort of-- is right there?
It's starting to
roar a little bit.
And this is where
we need to watch it.
Because if it can bubble over--
and that's what we don't want.
We don't want this huge vat
of jam to go bubbling over.
So this is where
I'm watching it.
And I'm just going to
see what plays out here.
But you see, all the
water's just going away.
It's all just going away,
which is pretty neat.
AUDIENCE: If you're
adding rosemary or basil,
those kind of herbs,
do you recommend
dry versus fresh, and then at
what point do you put it in?
During maceration
or during cooking?
VALERIE GORDON:
I'm a fan of fresh.
I just think you're going to
get a fuller-- you will get
a fresher flavor from a
fresh herb or a fresh fruit.
But again, if you don't
have it, go with dry.
Something like rosemary,
I would be careful with.
Rosemary is potent, as
is a bay leaf, much more
so than oregano
or basil or thyme.
I would throw that
in in maceration.
That's actually a
really interesting idea.
Yeah, I would throw
that in in maceration.
And then taste it.
And then you might want to
take it out before you cook it.
There might be enough
of that flavor in there.
And then, just put it
back in in the finish.
But if you are including
herbs in jams or any preserve,
you would probably
want to remove it
before you process it.
Because they will turn black,
which is not that cute.
That doesn't look
quite as delicious.
But like rosemary and pear
would be really, really good.
That would be great.
Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: So do you
store what you've
made in the refrigerator,
or do you use water baths?
VALERIE GORDON: I
do a water bath.
And there are instructions
for the water bath in there.
And you can really use-- I
suggest getting a canning pot.
You can actually use
any pot, any big pot,
to use a water bath.
And that is a way
to preserve it.
The water bath
process, essentially,
after you put hot jam into clean
jars with rubber-sealed lids,
you put it in there.
And then you immerse it in
boiling water for 10 minutes.
What that does is that
removes any excess air.
It's sort of that heat pushes
the air out and seals the jar.
And that makes it shelf-stable,
for most jams about 18 months.
You can also just put it into
a jar, or whatever container,
and refrigerate it.
Depending on the amount
of sugar that you use,
you'll be fine with
it in the refrigerator
anywhere from two
weeks to two months.
[SNEEZE IN AUDIENCE]
VALERIE GORDON: Bless you.
Bless you.
Anyone else?
Jams and marmalades are also
a really lovely holiday gift.
Instead of buying
something on the internet,
which there's nothing
wrong with that.
You know you can get a
nice book on the internet.
But since you're all
at your computers,
but sometimes it's nice
to get active, right?
It's nice to get active.
So now can people
see what's happening?
Is there a screen?
No?
OK.
So the bubbling is starting
to come down a little bit now.
And what you'll
see at this point
is you'll start to
get a slightly darker
color happening.
So we bubble up, and it all
turns like this white color.
And then as it
comes down, you'll
start to see this concentrated
red color come out of this.
And that's when you'll
know that most of the water
has gone away.
And then we're just watching it.
We're stirring.
We're tweaking for flavor.
We're tasting.
Does anyone want to come taste?
Come taste where it's at?
Ooh, shy girl.
She's all, don't call me.
[LAUGHTER]
VALERIE GORDON: Hysterical.
OK, Rosemary.
Will you come taste?
OK, so you're going
to let me know.
Ironically, even though
my book is called "Sweet,"
I tend toward slightly
lower sugar in things
than a lot of people who
work in this field do.
Do you see what's
happening there?
What's your real name?
AUDIENCE: Egregia.
VALERIE GORDON: Egregia.
Nice to meet you.
AUDIENCE: I do like
the name Rosemary.
VALERIE GORDON: Are you OK?
AUDIENCE: Oh, that's so good.
VALERIE GORDON: You're
OK with the sugar level?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
VALERIE GORDON: OK, cool.
Do you see it's getting
a little darker?
Right.
So we're just about
five minutes away.
Oh, here's another thing.
Thank you so much, Egregia.
Way to taste.
That was cool.
OK.
So people like chunky jam, and
some people like smooth jam.
I go a little smoother than
the general population.
I really like a really lovely
smooth, almost puree look
to jams.
A lot of people
like a chunkier jam,
where you can really
see the fruit.
And when you put it on
bread, it's like a terrain.
And they like it a little
bit more rustic, more country
style, neither is
right or wrong.
Again, go with
whatever you feel like.
If you are someone who
likes a really smooth jam,
at this point I would
switch out to a whisk.
And I would start whisking,
to just really break down
that fruit as much
as I possibly could,
and remove any fibers from it.
And then, it will
turn into a puree.
So there's a few
jams in this book--
the black and blue jam
in particular-- you
just want to like,
whisk, whisk, whisk.
Just to be careful, you do
want to turn off the heat
while you're whisking.
So you're not like-- the
potential of boiling sugars
flying in your
face is diminished
if you turn off the heat.
Another note.
I was told early in
my jam experimentation
that once you started
cooking, you couldn't really
turn it off.
You know what I mean?
You have to stand
there and stir.
Turn it off.
If you have to go the bathroom,
you need to take a phone call,
turn it off.
Walk away from it.
Nothing happens.
I swear to God.
I've done it over and over
and over, and nothing happens.
I've gone, returned emails,
come back, same outcome.
I was also told early in
my jam experimentation
that after you start,
you really can't
add more sugar, because it'll
crystallize and this and that.
I've totally added more
sugar at any point.
As long as you bring it up to
boiling, the sugar breaks down,
and it all emulsifies
and it's a non-issue.
So don't be scared of jam.
Don't be scared of it.
It's so easy to do.
And this recipe in
particular, so easy to do.
Totally interchangeable, also.
So you could do it
with any kind of berry.
You could do raspberry.
You can do blueberry.
You can do blackberry.
You can do-- we get
golden raspberries here,
which are amazing.
And they have this sort
of almost stone fruit
flavor to them.
Gorgeous, gorgeous jam.
Sweet, tart, wonderful.
Berries, again, they're
sort of an easy place
to start, because
there's so little
preparation that you have to do.
For most of them, all you
have to do is just rinse
and throw it in the pot.
That's all you have to do.
Very, very easy.
And then you can also do
some savory applications
with jams, which is really nice.
Strawberry vanilla bean jam
is great with goat cheese.
Really, really good with
tart, creamy goat cheese.
Delicious.
Strawberry vanilla bean jam
with ham is really good.
That's another fun little canape
that you can do, definitely.
Doing your own fruit
at the bottom yogurt.
Just get some good yogurt,
put your homemade jam on it.
It's a very satisfying thing.
Feels really nice to do that.
Grapes?
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Grapes do get a
little bit tedious
if you get a grape with seeds.
So it is not the easiest
fruit to start with.
And also, like a
Muscat grape, you also
want to remove the
skin sometimes.
So what you would have
to do with a grape jam
is sort of crush it.
You know what I mean?
Some people like to
do it in a food mill,
and then remove all the extra.
But crushing it, working
through a colander,
something like that.
It's a little bit
more labor intensive.
It could be slightly daunting
to a novice jam maker, I think.
But just know that
going into it.
Kyoto grapes do make some of
the most delicious jam ever.
It's a very fleshy grape.
So they have seeds in it,
but it's a really sort of-- I
mean, the grape
itself is like candy.
[? Hawes ?] Farms that sells
at the Santa Monica Farmers'
Market has those grapes.
They're also in Hollywood.
Excellent, excellent grape.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So when
you're tasting that,
does the taste profile change
when you add the [INAUDIBLE]?
VALERIE GORDON: I'm sorry,
what was the question?
AUDIENCE: So when you
taste it, it's hot.
Later on when you enjoy it at
temperature or [INAUDIBLE],
does the taste profile change?
VALERIE GORDON: Yes.
I would say, as a rule,
something room temperature,
you have the
fullest flavor with.
Because your tongue, right?
Your palate is
reacting to whatever
temperature is happening.
Even though you might not want,
you can take like a custard
that you're cooking
or something.
You taste more of the flavor
if it's room temperature,
if it's a similar
temperature to your mouth.
Right?
Because your mouth
isn't adjusting.
Jams, likes soup, like a
stock, like most sauces,
the flavor does come
out a little bit more
after it's sat for a few days.
Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Now that I'm
more thinking about it,
you are tasting whether
there is enough sugar,
whether it is too
hard or too smooth.
Does that actually change
from what you actually
get after it cools down?
VALERIE GORDON:
I don't think so.
I know I don't think
that's fairly subtle.
No, I don't think so.
But you will get more of
the ride of the flavor
when it's room temperature.
AUDIENCE: Have you ever
used chilies in any jams?
VALERIE GORDON: Totally.
I like spicy Asian food.
I go spicy Asian with almost
all of my personal savory eating
is where I go.
Chili and fruit is a
fun, fun combination.
And then, look at
barbecue sauce.
Right?
Barbecue sauce is a
jam, more or less.
It's a tomato jam that's been
cooked down and cooked down.
And then different spices
and flavorings and sugars,
molasses, have been added to it.
You can, totally.
Go for it.
Chili and apricot
is a fun combination
that you wouldn't
really suspect.
Chili, apricot, brown sugar?
Delicious delicious.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: For something like
strawberry or raspberry,
if you wanted it to be
seedless, [INAUDIBLE] strained?
VALERIE GORDON: Again, that's
where you sort of walk down
the road of a tedious project.
Yes, absolutely you can strain.
Harder to strain a strawberry,
you know what I mean?
And the seeds are
so infinitesimal.
And you'll see when you taste
this in a couple minutes.
It's so minute.
Raspberries, definitely.
Some people just really
prefer a seedless raspberry.
Your yield will be
much lower for sure,
because you're getting
the seeds out as well.
Again, you're using like a
really fine mesh strainer.
You have to work the fruit
over that to remove it.
AUDIENCE: Do you do that
in the beginning, when
the fruit starts boiling, or?
VALERIE GORDON: No.
I would cook it
down a little bit.
Now we're looking at a
totally different process
of jam making, though.
So I would cook it a little bit
so you break down the fruit.
Let it cool.
Then go over a mesh,
extract the sugar
and the pulp of the raspberry.
And then continue cooking.
But yeah, that's your day.
That's your day.
Absolutely.
OK, so now we've got some
pretty nice concentrated fruit
happening here.
So now we're looking
for doneness.
So I'm going to pick this up.
This is not quite there yet.
So what I like to
see at this point
is something kind of a little
bit thicker on my spoon.
And this is still just
falling right off.
I want to see something
just like a thicker
sauce on this spoon
before I stop cooking.
So here we've gotten rid of the
majority of our excess water.
And now, we're just
going for texture.
This is done.
You could pull this if you
wanted a really loose jam.
You could pull this now.
You could can it.
You could serve it up.
It would be absolutely fine.
But I do like things just
a little bit thicker,
not quite as watery.
And I'll show you on
this little plate,
there are couple of ways that
I outline in the book for you
to test your jam to
see if it's done.
One is to do what
I just did, which
is dip a teaspoon
into the pot and just
see how it falls off the spoon.
Things like plum jam, the
fig jam, stuff like that,
you'll see just a very clear
texture difference happening.
The other sort of classic way
of doing this-- and you'll read
about this in all
the old books--
is putting a couple of
ceramic plates in the freezer.
And then what you want
to see-- and then you
take one out when you
think it's about done.
You put a little bit
of jam onto that plate.
And then you run your
finger through the jam.
And if the jam stays
separate, it's done.
You're simulating what the jam
will be like when it's cool
and not 370 degrees.
But I find the more you do this,
if you just start to look at it
and you see it sort of appearing
as a slightly thickened sauce,
you're where you want
to be with your texture.
And again, this is
a point of taste.
Some people like a really thick
jam so it's almost like a pate.
Just keep cooking it.
AUDIENCE: How do
you-- so far, you
were talking about one main
cooking ingredient, the fruit,
and others like this.
Is it some mix of
fruits actually
to use [INAUDIBLE] there are
some combination out there?
VALERIE GORDON:
Well, absolutely.
Absolutely.
I mean, come on.
I mean, I wouldn't brush my
teeth and eat strawberry jam.
There's certain things that like
with any other kind of food.
And this is my general
message about making
desserts in general at home.
And it's just like
savory cooking.
There's really no
difference to it.
So any flavors that you like,
feel free to put together.
And then like when
you go to the market--
and I just can't encourage
all of you to do that enough,
if you're into food, if you're
into baking, whatever it is.
Go to the market.
Taste things together.
Smell things together.
And get a sense of what
you like to put together.
One of the most unusual
flavor combinations
that I do quite frequently
is apricot and basil.
They go so well together, it
is just the most amazing fruit
and herb combination
across the board.
And I do it in
every configuration.
A basil shortbread with apricot
jam, a basil panna cotta
with apricot jam.
An apricot galette
with basil cream.
It's a really shockingly
delicious flavor combination.
A great role of thumb
with fruit is, what grows
together goes together.
Things that are in
season at the same time
and grown in the same climate
generally taste good together.
Apples and grapes?
Same season, beautiful
combination, beautiful.
You'll see it now.
What grows together
goes together.
All right, this looks good.
This looks really good.
So we are going to taste
just a very traditional-- OK.
So we see now,
this looks thicker.
I'm hoping you
guys can see this.
And it's sort of cloyed.
It wants to hang out on
the spoon a little bit more
when it comes down.
And it's got this-- it's just
more viscous and less watery.
So I'm going to turn this off.
One other little
cautionary thing.
When you turn off your jam,
when you go and make it
at home tomorrow, after
you have to turn off
the fire-- most of us don't have
induction units at home-- when
you turn off the fire, you
turn off the electric range,
make sure you stir it
a little bit after.
Because that's still
holding the heat.
And it's really, really sad
when you burn your pot of jam.
That's kind of a bummer.
You know what I mean?
And what you want to feel on
the bottom of your pot is slick.
And this is one of
the other reasons
why I love a heat-proof spatula.
And I think I should
get a sponsorship
with a heat-proof
spatula company,
is because you can really
feel the pot with it.
You can feel like that
it's nice and smooth.
There's nothing hanging
on to the end of the pot.
Whereas just with
the tip of a spoon,
it it's hard to get
that same sense.
So what we're
going to enjoy here
is some bread and butter
and strawberry jam,
which is pretty cute.
Come on up.
So again, this is
a little bit looser
that it will be after it cools,
because this is pretty hot.
But this is a cute trait.
AUDIENCE: Valerie, where
are your three locations?
VALERIE GORDON: Our
original location,
that we now call
The Mother Ship,
it is at 3360 West First Street.
It's between Virgil
and Commonwealth,
two blocks east of Vermont.
That's where we manufacture all
of the chocolate, all the jams,
all of the petit fours we
ship all over the country.
The other two locations,
one is in Echo Park.
That's our tea house and bakery.
And the other one is that the
Grand Central Market downtown,
which is currently
being refurbished.
It's pretty exciting.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's good.
VALERIE GORDON: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
Thanks for coming.
So you'll see it's a
very different experience
to enjoy this just-cooked
homemade jam than something
out of a Smuckers jar.
No offense to Smuckers,
no offense to Smuckers.
Just to give you all a little
bit of history of what I do
and the company and sort of the
genesis of the book, as Julie
said, I'm totally self-taught.
I started baking when
I was eight years old.
I never went to culinary school,
and I don't call myself a chef.
People always say, well,
what do I call you?
And I say "Valerie."
Just something about
the word "chef."
I don't wear a coat.
I wear an apron in the kitchen.
I just cook.
I don't know.
I make things, and
most of them are sweet.
And I hope that they're
pretty and that they're
delicious and memorable.
Our company, my partner
and I-- my partner in life
as well as business-- we
started our little concern
9 and 1/2 years ago from an
apartment in the South Carthay
area of Los Angeles with
six flavors of toffee.
I'd always made different sort
of confections and cookies
and things like that.
And primarily, we had done a
lot of this stuff for gifting.
And we decided it was time
to start our own thing.
So it was a very fun
startup, insane situation
where our second
bedroom was our office.
Our dining room
was curtained off,
and that's where we did
packaging and ribboning,
and we were storing
our chocolates.
And you all will very
much appreciate this.
In 2004, when we
started the company,
the only way you could place
an order was via fax or phone.
And our order form for
these six flavors of toffee
was like four pages long.
It had descriptions of each
flavor and the different box
sizes, and you know,
stuff like that.
We did figure out a way to
take-- and it was like checks.
It was personal checks.
And that was kind of it for
our first holiday season.
We've grown a little bit
since then, thankfully.
And one of the ways that
we've grown is into a bakery.
Julie asked that I
bring some cakes today.
And the cakes that I
have here, I would say
are the most popular
cakes that we make.
And one of the most interesting
and popular cakes that we make
is the Blum's
coffee crunch cake,
which I am putting
crunch on right now.
It is a historic cake.
And this is one of
those cakes that
has an enormous amount of
emotional attachment for people
who grew up with this cake.
There were Blum's Bakeries,
eight different locations,
in Northern and
Southern California.
They were all gone
by the late '70s.
And this is a cake
that I knew as a child.
And it was a celebratory cake.
I was asked to resurrected this
cake by a food editor in 2009.
And because she was doing a
story for the Los Angeles Times
Magazine that, when
you're getting married,
you should be able to have
any kind of cake you want.
It shouldn't just be a white
cake with white buttercream
and a couple on top.
Like, if you like
a hummingbird cake,
you should be able to get that.
If you like a coffee cake, you
should be able to get that.
And she also was from San
Francisco, originally,
and remembered the Blum's
coffee crunch cake.
And when she said,
can you do this?
I was like, oh my God.
I know that cake so well.
I've had such an
overwhelming desire
to have that cake so many times.
So it was sort of a thrill.
And I tested the cake, tested
the cake, tested the cake.
I did a lot of internet research
about different interpretations
of the cake that had
happened over the years.
And after testing about
12 different recipes,
I honed it down and
created my own version
of the Blum's
coffee crunch cake.
And when this thing was in just
this little picture in the Los
Angeles Times Magazine,
the number of phone
calls we received
was amazing, amazing.
And like every 60,
70, 80-year-old person
would had ever eaten this
cake called, and was like,
I remember this cake.
I grew up with this cake.
This is the most amazing cake.
And we were flooded.
Thank you so much
for coming today.
This is a thrill, I have to say.
[APPLAUSE]